all right well fox businesses charlie
gasparino with a new york post op-ed
titled inflation is biden's fault and
only biden's fault larry kudlow host of
kudlow on fox business joins me now i
got this mysterious accent earlier i
don't know if you heard kudlow who the
heck is that guy anyway uh all right
let's talk about the feds uh federal
officials the white house you know
they're repeatedly claiming that these
gas price increases are solely due to
the conflict in europe we know that's
not true
rather than the reckless anti-oil and
gas policies pursued over the last year
when is the biden administration going
to just give in and give up to the fact
that they're they're
responsible well first of all you have
to love peter ducey just in general
that's very important
and
second of all julie i don't think the
bidens will ever fess up to it they'll
never own the problem and by the way
that's an issue because if you don't own
an administration that doesn't make the
right diagnosis and take ownership and
then it'll never move towards solving
the problem so you got a couple things
cooking here right for the past year
we've had massive deficit spending and
the federal reserve has accommodated it
with huge money supply increases that's
number one you just saw them with this
omnibus appropriations bill which is
another one and a half trillion dollars
in spending about seven percent above
last year's level that's what i call
wrong direction by the way the ear marks
make it even worse the second point is
this
massive regulatory octopus that is
strangling the oil and gas industry and
you know
there's been a debate about uh
permitting and leasing on federal lands
well basically they've stopped pipelines
and they've stopped any new leases
because they've got this crazy idea it's
called the social cost of carbon which
is an
invented makeup thing that goes back
centuries and tries to predict upstream
downstream global it's all nonsense but
it's serious nonsense because even
producers julia on private lands which
is where most of the oil and gas comes
from
they are being stopped by these new
regulatory inventions
some of it's the endangered species some
of it's the clean water some of it's the
nepa permitting some of it's this
social cost of carbon so
we have
2 million barrels a day
less in oil than we had at the
pre-pandemic peak and if you actually
change the policy like if president
biden sent a special diplomatic envoy
to midland texas to make peace with the
oil and gas industry they could make up
that 2 million bowel shortfall very
rapidly and
and if he would send another envoy to
alberta canada
and to the excel pipeline people there's
a they could finish that pipeline within
a year
that's what industry sources say and
that would be another 800 000 barrels so
i can get you to almost 3 million
barrels per day if the regulatory
octopus tentacles would be removed but i
don't see any chance of that i should
not answer that i'm glad that you
brought that up because you know talking
about this you know we are more than a
million and a half barrels per day under
our peak production in 2019 as you just
pointed out when oil by the way if you
remember averaged 57
70 of americans are favoring increased
oil here in the us and gas production
this is a make it in america goal the
biden administration needs to quickly
embrace
yeah look at i mean
instead of going to iran and venezuela
and all these dictators sure let's go to
our friends but you know if you're
accusing them of price gouging and
excess profits very mean nasty stuff
that's preventing the industry from
making new investments look ferc the
federal energy regulatory commission is
stopping any new pipelines any new
pipelines period full stop now let me
tell you something sake says in the
press room yesterday the day before
pipelines don't matter because they
don't really produce the the oil well
you can't produce
you can't produce what you're not going
to ship so they know they can't do that
that's why pipelines have to be approved
it would be like milking a cow and
leaving the milk on the barn's floor you
got to have pipelines and oil production
they don't seem to understand that it's
a rather hopeless cause the thing is we
could be snapping back all this blaming
of putin look i'd love to blame putin
for everything under the sun but you
can't pin this you'll see next month's
inflation will reflect the putin rise in
oil and gasoline prices but as you noted
earlier and others have this thing's
been going on all year past 12 14 months
gasoline prices world oil prices because
we're killing
one of our greatest industries for
heaven's sakes and my worry is with it
with an eight percent inflation julie
whatever happens it is not going to end
well bidens woke washington it's not
going to end well i think this
the horse is out of the barn and i'm not
sure how you're going to get it back i
got to get your take on msnbc's andrea
mitchell praising putin's price hike
messaging from biden um and actually
arguing that americans are willing to
put up with surging pump costs to defend
ukraine watch this
and talking to members of congress
that they now see the politics right now
and it may not last
that the american people are behind this
and
more
likely are willing to take
a hit at the pump
if this means not bringing war here
right like that's another way to message
us i might argue yeah and putin's price
hike is a great way to message it oh and
i'm not done and democratic congressman
raul ruiz uh seems to be right on
message watch
my wife and i feel it at the gas tank
already
we're paying a lot of money and american
families are feeling it at the gas tank
too
we have to ask ourselves what
what is it we stand for
as a democracy
to protect other democracies and if it
means paying a few extra cents at the
gas tank then we're willing to pay that
really what do you make of the dems
message there that we're willing to pay
the price for it wasn't putin's fault
two weeks ago our gas prices were up for
biden so we're willing to pay for
biden's mistakes
it's not going to fly
early polls by the way already showing
it's not going to fly look
part of this pole collapse
i mean part of biden's pole collapse
over the past six or nine months is
directly attributable to excess federal
spending high oil prices and high
gasoline prices inflation is the number
one
issue out there so this stuff's not
gonna this stuff's not gonna fly look
andrea mitchell is an old friend of mine
but i would make this suggestion she
should go talk to her husband the very
distinguished and dear friend of mine
alan greenspan who will tell her that
when you have skyrocketing inflation
because you're choking off oil and gas
because you're spending too much money
it will not end well and i think folks
have this foreboding unfortunately i'd
love it to be different but i'll say
this julie the cavalry is coming
change is on the way we just have to get
through the next seven or eight months
how's that
we'll try larry kudlow thank you great
to see you have a wonderful weekend